Nos frotamos los ojos, verificamos los filtros,
pensando que alguien se burlaba de nosotros con la ayuda de las cámaras
pero la anguila era real.
Era la primera anguila verde fluorescente que encontramos
y cambió totalmente mi carrera.
Así que tuve que dejar los corales,
hacer un equipo con el experto en peces John Sparks
e iniciar una búsqueda por el mundo
para determinar si este fenómeno era algo frecuente.
Los peces son mucho más interesantes que los corales,
porque tienen una visión muy desarrollada y algunos de ellos incluso tienen
--visto por la forma en la cual los fotografié--
lentes en sus ojos para aumentar la fluorescencia.
Y quise profundizar más en este tema.
Hemos creado nuevos equipos
para escudriñar los arrecifes en todo el mundo
en busca de vida fluorescente.
Es un poco como la escena de "E.T. llama a casa".
Nadábamos por allí acompañados de esta luz azul
buscando respuestas
buscando animales que absorbían esta luz y volvían a emitirla.
Por fin encontramos nuestra fantástica anguila Kaupichphys.
Es una anguila muy tímida y solitaria y sabemos muy poco sobre ella.
Miden poco más de un dedo
y pasan aproximadamente el 99,9 % de su vida escondidas debajo de una piedra.
Salen a aparearse durante las noches de luna llena,
y durante las noches de luna llena, el agua se convierte en azul.
A lo mejor es una manera de verse mutuamente
de encontrarse rápidamente y aparearse
para luego volver bajo sus rocas por un largo tiempo.
Pero luego empezamos a encontrar más vida marina fluorescente
como este sargo verde fluorescente
con sus rayas horizontales en la cabeza y el cuello
casi camuflado, y brillando con la misma intensidad
que este coral fluorescente de aquí.
Después de este pez,
vimos este pez león rojo fluorescente,
camuflado y oculto en esta roca.
La única vez que lo vimos
fue sobre algas rojas fluorescentes o corales rojos fluorescentes.
Más tarde, nos encontramos con este pez-lagarto verde fluorescente camuflado.
Hay muchos tipos de pez lagarto
y bajo luz blanca, son prácticamente idénticos.
Pero bajo luz fluorescente
vemos muchos patrones,
vemos las diferencias entre ellos.
En total, y hemos documentado esto el año pasado,
hemos descubierto más de 200 especies de peces biofluorescentes.
Una de mis fuentes de inspiración
es el artista y biólogo francés Jean Painlevé.
Realmente encarna este espíritu emprendedor y creativo de la biología.
Creó su propio equipo, diseñó sus propias cámaras
y el caballito de mar, el Hippocampus erectus le fascinaba.
Fue el primero en filmar el nacimiento de un caballito de mar.
Este es el caballito de mar macho.
Fue uno de los primeros peces que evolucionó a nadar en posición vertical
con el cerebro colocado en la parte superior de la cabeza.
Los machos dan a luz. Son criaturas fenomenales.
Painlevé se quedó despierto durante días.
Llegó a ponerse una visera en la cabeza que disparaba descargas eléctricas
para capturar este momento.
Me hubiera gustado haberle presentado a Painlevé
el momento en el cual descubrimos los caballitos de mar biofluorescentes
de la misma especie que él estudió.
Aquí está nuestro video.
(Música)
Son unos peces muy enigmáticos.
Podemos nadar por encima de ellos y no verlos.
Estaban camuflados entre las algas, también de color rojo fluorescente,
pero tienen una vista excelente
y se someten a un largo ritual de apareamiento.
Y quizá la están usando en este sentido.
Pero la situación se volvió tensa
cuando encontramos rayas verdes fluorescentes
porque las rayas son una subclase de peces cartilaginosos
que incluyen...
tiburones.
Soy un biólogo de corales.
Pero alguien tiene que ir a ver si los tiburones son fluorescentes.
Y ahí estoy.
(Risas)
Pensé: "Tal vez debería volver a los corales".
Resulta que estos tiburones no son fluorescentes.
Y luego encontramos
en una garganta oscura y profunda de la costa de California
el primer tiburón biofluorescente
de los que nadan por debajo de los surfistas.
Aquí está.
Miden alrededor de un metro y se llama el tiburón durmiente.
En inglés, su nombre hace referencia al vientre porque, al sentirse amenazado,
traga agua y se hincha hasta el doble de su tamaño
y se esconde debajo de una roca,
para no no ser devorado por los depredadores.
Aquí están nuestras primeras imágenes de estos tiburones biofluorescentes.
Son magníficos con estos patrones distintos,
con partes fluorescentes y otros que no,
y también tienen estas manchas brillantes
mucho más brillante que otras partes.
Todo esto es muy bonito de ver.
Para mí fue algo hermoso,
¿pero qué significa para el tiburón?
¿Pueden distinguirlo ellos mismos?
Hemos consultado los libros
pero no existe referencia alguna sobre la visión de estos tiburones.
Así que llevé a este tiburón al oculista Ellis Loew de la Universidad de Cornell,
quien encontró que este tiburón tiene una vista clara y precisa
en esta interfaz de color azul-verde,
tal vez 100 veces mejor que nuestra visión en la oscuridad
pero solo ven azul y verde.
Lo que hace es tomar de este mundo azul
absorber el color azul y crear el color verde.
Crea un contraste que pueden distinguir.
Tenemos un modelo
que demuestra que crean un mundo para ver todos estos patrones.
Descubrimos también que los machos y las hembras
tienen diferentes patrones para diferenciarse entre ellos.
Nuestro último descubrimiento se realizó a pocos kilómetros de aquí
en las Islas Salomón.
Nadando por la noche, me encontré con la primera tortuga biofluorescente.
Así pues, pasamos de los peces, a los tiburones, a los reptiles,
--y esta es información de hace poco más que un mes--
pero esto demuestra que no sabemos casi nada
sobre la visión de la tortuga carey.
Me hace pensar en lo que nos queda por aprender.
Aquí, en las Islas Salomón,
quedan solo unos pocos miles de hembras de esta especie.
Este es uno de los mejores lugares para ellas.
Esto nos muestra cuán necesario es proteger a estos animales
mientras están todavía aquí, y entenderlos.
En cuanto a la biofluorescencia
yo quería saber hasta dónde llega.
¿La encontraremos hasta en lo más profundo del océano?
Así que empezamos a usar submarinos
equipados delante con luces azules especiales.
Y nos sumergimos
hasta descubrir una cosa importante:
más allá de mil metros
disminuye.
No hay vida marina biofluorescente por debajo de los mil metros,
no hay casi nada, más que oscuridad.
Es básicamente un fenómeno de aguas poco profundas.
Por debajo de los mil metros
encontramos una zona bioluminiscente
donde 9 de cada 10 animales producen su propia luz,
que brilla y parpadea.
Al tratar de sumergirme más
--aquí me pueden ver en un mono-traje subacuático
durante una inmersión que algunos llamaron
"Jacques Cousteau se encuentra con Woody Allen".
(Risas)
Durante la exploración me preguntaba
¿cómo podemos interactuar respetuosamente con la vida subacuática?
Ya que nos adentramos en una nueva era de exploración,
donde tenemos que tener mucho cuidado
y servir de ejemplo en la forma en que exploramos.
Así que junto con el ingeniero Rob Wood, de la Universidad de Harvard,
para crear dedos esponjosos para robots submarinos,
para interaccionar con la vida marina de la manera menos invasiva posible.
La mayor parte de las tecnologías para explorar las profundidades del océano
vienen del mundo del petróleo o militar
los cuales, como es sabido, no se preocupan por ser respetuosos.
Algunos corales pueden tener más de mil años.
No queremos llegar y aplastarlos con una gran garra metálica.
Así que mi sueño es algo así:
Es de noche, estoy en un submarino,
tengo guantes hápticos
y pongo las bases de un laboratorio delante de mi submarino,
donde mis dedos robóticos esponjosos
recogen y ponen las cosas en frascos suavemente,
para que podamos seguir con nuestras investigaciones.
De vuelta a las poderosas aplicaciones que podemos desarrollar.
Aquí se puede ver un cerebro vivo
que usa el ADN de criaturas marinas fluorescentes
este en particular es de medusas y corales,
para iluminar el cerebro vivo y ver sus conexiones.
Es curioso que usamos los colores rojo, verde y azul
solo para satisfacer nuestra intuición humana,
para poder ver mejor nuestro cerebro.
Y aún más impresionante
es mi colega Vicente Pieribone, de Yale,
quien creó y desarrolló una proteína fluorescente
sensible a la tensión eléctrica.
Así podemos ver cuando una única neurona dispara.
Básicamente están viendo un portal hacia la conciencia
diseñada por las criaturas marinas.
Y esto me lleva de vuelta a la perspectiva y las relaciones.
Desde el espacio profundo
nuestro universo se parece a una célula del cerebro humano
y aquí estamos en las profundidades del océano,
donde encontramos criaturas marinas y células
que pueden iluminar la mente humana.
Y espero que con las mentes iluminadas
podemos reflexionar sobre la interconectividad global de la vida
y averiguar qué otras cosas nos reserva el futuro
si mantenemos los océanos limpios.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)